I wrote a piece for the wall sorry for
the Washington Post that came out the
morning after the election on Wednesday
the fifth where I explained what I
thought we needed to do as Republicans
to find our way out of the wilderness
and I suggested that we return to the
first principles of the Republican Party
limited government economic freedom
those are the principles those have been
always been the first and second article
of faith for Republicans and that's what
can propel us back into the majority
because that I think people will come to
realize particularly where we're going
with the bailout and where the economy
is going that that we simply cannot dig
our way out of this by replacing
economic incentives with political
incentives I mentioned I wrote that
while Adam Smith's Wealth of Nations may
be on the discount rack this year the
free market is still the most efficient
way to allocate resources and human
allocate capital and human resources in
an economy and Americans know it now I I
think that that certainly is the case
I think Republicans also need to realize
that focusing on the wedge issues of the
past will not grow the Republican Party
the tone and tenor of the immigration
debate has done the Republican Party
immeasurable damage and focusing on
social issues while ignoring our
principles on limited government and
free markets will not broaden our base
but I am optimistic I really am
when you're at rock bottom there's only
one way to go but not just for that but
but I think that we as I mentioned our
strongest suit as and I'm speaking as a
Republican here and I know that
everybody here is not but our strongest
suit is limited government economic
freedom individual liberty and if we'll
get back to those first principles with
groups like reason to be there as the
lodestar for us then we can certainly
gain favor again and also educate those
who need to be educated and and much as
reason has done for 40 years I've been
so pleased to have an association with
reason for a long time I headed the
Goldwater Institute for seven years and
I always wanted to be like The Reason
Foundation and dealing with Bob Poole
and Bill Eggers and others on
transportation and other issues so I've
admired reason for a long time long
before I got to Congress but I wish that
more of my colleagues would subscribe to
reason and also subscribe to the
principles that you've enunciated so
well so thank you so much for having me
here it's an honor to be here at this
anniversary
you